it's ally of smiley and I'm one of the
family directors here so
I was really keen to develop my online
presence I felt that I was using sort of
outdated methods where I was just purely
calling candidates just messaging and
just doing just doing online online
activities that pretty much every other
recruit was doing so I feel like I
wanted to do something different
definitely create more engagement
definitely create more of a brand I
think within the first hour of my first
video I had picked up a new client which
I'm now working with and closing deals
with so you know immediate doesn't
immediate effect to me
I think it's very very engaging it's
very easy I think that it's not
something that you can't pick up and
then it's just being committed to
actually follow up and continue the
process I think the way that you've done
it and the way that you've create this
program makes it so easy for everyone to
do so if you want to do something
different if you want to create a
personal brand and drive your engagement
then do something different to other
people are doing and this is this is
that